for nearly five decades gene Hackman was
a staple of American cinema during that
time the San Bernadino born actor won
four Golden Globes to BAFTAs in two
Academy Awards while starring in classic
films like Hoosiers Unforgiven and gets
shorty to name just a very few since the
early 2000s however we haven't seen or
heard much from the accomplished actor
and All American tough guy so what's
Hackman been up to retired
first and foremost Hackman is retired
which explains why we haven't seen much
of the guy lately his last role was in
the 2004 romantic comedy welcome to
Mooseport in which he acted alongside
sitcom star Ray Romano
after that Hackman called it quits but
he didn't really make a big deal out of
it
he told Reuters I'm not going to act any
longer I've been told not to say that
over the last few years in case some
real wonderful part comes up but I
really don't want to do it any longer
novelist just because Hackman retired
from acting doesn't mean he's not
working in fact he's actually pinned
quite a few novels in addition to
co-writing three works of historical
fiction Hackman has also released two
solo efforts Old West revenge story
payback at morning peak and police
thriller pursuit these days Hackman
greatly prefers writing to acting he
told Reuters I like the loneliness of it
actually it's similar in some ways to
acting but it's more private and I feel
like I have more control over what I'm
trying to say and do painter in addition
to acting and writing novels Hackman's
other artistic pursuits include painting
and he's pretty darn good at it the
accomplished actor actually studied art
at the Art Students League of New York
as a young man maybe I can
feed myself as a artist I was waiting to
be an actor oh my god doing something
almost all the time drawing or painting
he's been creating art ever since but
rarely shows what he calls his quote on
shoval work to the public he has however
donated some heart work to charitable
causes no grandpa roles there's one
pretty big reason why we'll likely never
see Hackman come out of retirement for
another big-screen role the aging actor
simply isn't interested in playing older
characters according to contact music
Hackman said at my age they would have
me playing grandfathers and
great-grandfather's it's not a heck of a
lot of fun nobody puts Hackman in a box
behind the scenes perhaps the main
reason Hackman is happy to be done with
showbiz is that he really doesn't miss
all of the behind the scenes nonsense
that comes with the job
he told contact music I don't miss the
business I miss the process of being on
set with actors when things get cooking
but there's so much crap olla in order
to get there it's just too painful when
you've accomplished all that Hackman has
there's really no reason to take anyone
else's crap Ola if you didn't like it
then that's his problem an important
narration although Hackman doesn't lend
his physical presence to the screen
anymore he's not afraid to lend his
voice to worthwhile projects Hackman
sort of came back from retirement to
narrate 2016's the unknown flag raiser
of Iwo Jima a one-hour documentary
aiming to correct the misidentification
of one soldier in Joe Rosenthal's famous
World War 2 photograph the picture
conceals an extraordinary case of
mistaken identity
Hackman himself dropped out of high
school at the age of 16 to enlist in the
Marine Corps where he served as a field
radio operator for over four years
the balls in him Bastion in there
will he act again well probably not
hackman seems quite satisfied with the
arc of his award filled career speaking
of which the actor seems to have
distance himself so much from that part
of his life he may not even know where
his awards are he told GQ I don't have
any memorabilia around the house
there isn't any movie stuff except the
poster downstairs next to the pool table
of Errol Flynn from Dawn Patrol I'm not
a sentimental guy still there is one
role that could possibly entice Hackman
out of retirement he explained I like
Edmund in The Count of Monte Cristo
having been able to keep that terrible
vengeance in his soul for so many years
and then carrying out what he thought
were justified events in the end I like
that as a novel thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]